this video was sponsored by Lantern
Smith I am going to give myself one week
to learn one of my favorite po
performances Jesus that's different than
the way I normally do it there's a whole
part in there I was
missing hey that wasn't bad G is one
extra mother I will say
that hey Drex here from Drex Factor po
sharing with you the love of Po spinning
and flow Arts to benefit your body brain
and today I am taking on a new challenge
but before we dive in let just give a
quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyrro ter light toys spinballs
and Ultra poy for helping them make the
videos on this channel possible you can
learn more about all these awesome
companies and the work that they're
doing to support flow artists like
yourself by checking out the links down
in the description of this video and
special thanks to the non- bu business
friend of the channel Becca Becken thank
you so very much for supporting my
channel my work and my mission now in
the dance world it's very very common as
you are learning how to do basic steps
and Combos and the like that the teacher
is going to create choreography for you
and you are meant to learn that
choreography we don't really do that in
the P or flow Arts World though
generally speaking when we kind of lift
stuff from other people it's specific
tricks but you know what there's no
reason that we can't do this and I would
like to give it a shot specifically I'm
going to take one of my favorite po
performances which would be g's firep
performance at San Francisco dcom and
I'm going to try and learn his
choreography I am going to give myself
one week that is 7 days to learn G's
choreography and try to perform it in
full myself so first things first is
what I'm going to try and do is I'm
going to set up a set of contact POI
that are going to be reasonbly close in
length and weight to what G is using in
the original video in the hopes that
that makes my own reproduction of his
choreography a little bit more
consistent and that is a perfect
opportunity to talk about the sponsor
for this video Lantern Smith Lantern
Smith makes my very favorite contact PO
on the market the reason being that they
use these Nifty little cartridges inside
of their contact poy heads and that
means that I can very easily change the
length of the tethers very quickly and I
can add or remove weight if I so choose
in order to make these heads lighter or
heavier in order to get them closer to
the weight of the heads that g was using
in his video so one of my challenges
this first day will be to try and dial
in the weight of my contact POI to be as
close as possible to the ones that g was
using in his performance thank you
Lantern Smith for making this project
possible okay so it's looking like G is
using POI that run uh about up to the
end of his biceps uh just short of his
his shoulder and that there's a bit in
the beginning where he's doing pendulums
back and forth at this length in time
with the music that I should be able to
use to dial in proper weight
here okay so I think I need to add one
more ballast slug into these
heads all right take
two Perfect Two ball slugs it is our
goal for today is to get down the first
30 seconds of this performance bring it
up I think I adopt this pose
stall left hand flame breake so from
here we take it up Jesus that's
different than the way normally do it
wow hang on that just screwed me
[Applause]
[Music]
up
all right I'm going to call that day one
let's see how I did all right so day two
it is overcast and a little chilly I
have made two changes uh starting into
day two here the first one is that I ran
into some pretty significant problems
keeping track of what side of the stage
G was moving towards and the reason for
that is is that I'm just kind of
struggling to mirror his uh movements
and so what I've actually done is
prepared a version of this video that
flips the video horizontally so that now
I just follow exactly what I see
happening on screen number two is I'm
actually going to shorten up the poy
just a little bit which thank you again
to Lantern Smith for making such a poy
where that's easy to
do first up let's review what we
[Music]
know
yeah oh Lord so something that was not
clear to me until just now is that g has
the opposite dominant direction of spin
that I do he's counterclockwise dominant
I'm
clockwise this is going to be a
challenge so we've got here and I bring
this around
boom and it's going to take it around
two
boom one two one Jesus Oh that punk
changed the length of his poy when did
that happen so stall comes around boom I
wrap as they come in oh that stall is
supposed to be happening out to Stage
right how did I miss
that this bit is intricate boom boom
boom take it right back oh and again
jeez op Pete there's so much going on in
here oh my God that's so
fast damn it okay so all of the
equipment has officially failed me today
I'm going to make a stab at one more
take and then I'm going to call it a
[Applause]
day
[Music]
[Applause]
all right so day three check-in I've got
the bones of the choreography in there
but I definitely do not have a good feel
for the timing in a lot of parts it
dawned on me I've got another version of
this performance that I can look at for
guidance that is g did another version
of this with LED POI at spinfest in 2010
unexpectedly it also created a major
challenge for me today there's a section
where G is playing around once again
with butterflies in the San Francisco
decom version and he's playing around
with pendulums and udalls in the
spinfest version was one of these a
mistake was one of them deliberate was
the spinfest version a revision of that
original choreography and the spinfest
version is the more refined and Polished
version it's hard for me to tell I think
that
I'm just going to flip a coin on it
and Tails for spinfest I'm actually a
little disappointed with that answer I
might just go ahead and do the San
Francisco decom version after all
sometimes flipping the coin tells you
what you really want all right let's go
outside and get to work da da da
da pretty sure that that's a mistake in
the choreography but I'm going to learn
it anyway talking around da da da I got
the side right that's the question du du
uh yeah cool all right I was tur to the
right side so this part's definitely
right I think it's right left right
coming out a getting the specific beats
of this is going to be a challenge boom
boom boom
boom good Lord there's like so many bits
to parse out left tuck boom is it the
left stalling up there it is the left
stalling up there yay something made
sense
du uh God damn it I'm coming towards the
camera and I go right left
du you know I think I'm going to call
that it for the day I'm a day ahead I
think I can afford to uh not have to do
all the
[Music]
things
all right it's nearly 1:00 so I've been
out this for nearly 2 hours I am done
for the day but at least I gained
another 30
seconds day four and the temperature has
dropped by 30° I really do not mind at
all cuz I have been just sweating
buckets the past few days working on
this piece so I have a minute and a half
left to learn of this piece today so
there's a part of me that is feeling
just a little bit ambitious let's see if
I can pull it off so we have got boom I
think boom boom me verify that oh my God
I can see the end of the timeline for
the video and it is giving me hope boom
boom here
here up quarter time here here judeus
priest boom boom boom here here forward
up and around cool Hot Diggity Dog Drex
good job cool so that's a third of what
I want to get done
today oh it's
fast damn so bloody
fast hey that wasn't bad up out and down
and then the left hand is going to do
some stuff I'm at 304 right now there's
about 30 seconds left in the whole
performance yay
over I think that's what's going on
there
left G is one extra mother I will say
that around oh I'm so close to the end
good Lord
a
a at least that part's intuitive to
me do not like so I think that's
intended to be an Archer weave going
around
there and that's the end right there oh
my God it's so close it's so close it's
so
close going need to be short for the end
do
it
where does that happen y That's full
length right there that's full length
too that's where it's happening ah so I
just realized that g is shortening his
poy that extra beat he's doing with the
fountain oh that's sneaky okay whole
thing with music now let's make it
[Music]
happen
and that is the end of the
song day five it is 40 degrees out and I
hate it so the good news is that I've
learned all the individual pieces of
choreography over the course of the past
few days yay um now I need to put them
all together cuz I think the thing I
want to really get out of this is uh to
see the spots where I'm getting off time
and also to just try and put all the
pieces together so if I can get just
like one or two run throughs today that
involve everything I'll be real happy
all right so first order business is I'm
just going to Mark through everything
that I currently know and see where that
uh see where that leaves me as we step
back we do Left Right bom buom leftover
out boom BM buom and B oh my God I am
not feeling this weather friends I am
not feeling this weather at
[Music]
all boom
boom here around here here here turn
around and we get to
the part again from here uh I'm drawing
a blank oh that's right here here right
stalls and we have right I'm trying to
remember the details of this boom boom
boom boom boom isolation no that's not
an isolation shoot oh that's where the
snake happens right so we take it around
like
so and that's the end all that from the
top again friends all that from the top
take it around and in out around this is
why we rehearse here here around and
back oh my brain is starting to turn
mush it's not a good sign and we wrap it
up right left right come around over
over up out boom boom boom boom boom
boom I am clown shoes today
everybody boom boom and we stall wait
for this truck to get past me because
that's the thing we're doing right
now hey I think that was the whole thing
and let's try a music and see how we're
doing yay that's a good sign again if I
can just get one take with music that's
reasonably solid I will be pretty damn
happy oh my God there's a whole part in
there I was Miss
listen Okay well at least I made it all
the way through let's let's let's do
that
[Music]
again okay let's do it one more time and
then I'm going to call it a
day Okay I lied one more take there's
last takes and then there's last Tak
[Music]
no ah I'm sorry I just need to call it h
I did not get one successful run through
of this
unfortunately um but I'm just exhausted
and I've been at this now for uh and
then close to an hour and a half and I'm
just reaching my fatigue Point um so I'm
going to call it for the day I'm going
to review the footage and I'm going to
figure out next
steps so it is
day six oh my goodness day six so full
disclosure I crash really hard yesterday
this has been both very physically as
well as mentally exhausting I'm going to
try and go easy on myself today I need
to um look at some of the takes that I
was doing yesterday and see some of the
spots where I was running into trouble I
actually have set up a little thing
where I can uh in my video editing
program view both uh G's performance as
well as mine side by side in order to
try and get a handle on uh what's
similar and what's
different uh it is 40 degrees out again
today and I hate it all right so I think
first order of business is to work
through all of my notes Here one two d d
and that's the end of the first phrase
boom boom that's why I keep being L that
that's the count I'm missing take it
around here cool it is so cold out no
magusta no that's right that's a turn to
the right okay that's what we needed
right there okay what's the next
note it is the split time noodling
section God help me we take this
around right over left under right under
left over good freaking
Lord yep that totally makes sense now
I'm not going to say totally but it
makes enough sense hey the sun's finally
coming my way that's a good sign I think
I can I think I
can cool all right now
music see how this goes for me
[Music]
here so unfortunately the battery has
failed in um my vlogging camera yet
again so I'm just going to do the best I
can with this one I'm sorry
[Music]
folks that was not
bad
[Music]
so that take wasn't bad but I think I've
got a better one in me so I'm going to
give it one more chance
[Music]
today
yeah well friends day seven one week is
officially here it is 4:00
p.m. on Friday November 3rd and I have
the dance studio booked to shoot video
of this of my version of G's
performance in 5 and 1 half hours so
yesterday I felt like was a big win by
and large the pieces are there so I'm
going to watch through this last take
from yesterday give myself notes and
then head
outside did he shorten up his poy in
that stall he did oh my God that's why
he's going through that section so fast
that makes so much more sense now okay I
need to do those pivots faster I
definitely need a version of this video
with G that includes the intro from his
spinfest performance I think I have some
ideas for some of the music cues in
there but I'm going to reedit this video
right quick and then head
outside I'm going to go ahead and Mark
through the whole piece uh once maybe
twice and then just grind on it set the
music going and do as many takes as I
can inside of an hour this
be God this bit such a nightmare going
to take this hoodie off that is still a
bit of a challenge boom boom boom boom
boom all right all that with music now
see how I
do oh I'm way
ahead
oh God but it's the wrong
side well I've at least got the the end
part down pat well I wanted to run this
for a solid hour but the batteries on my
phone are getting low and I'm GNA have
to run this thing top to bottom at the
studio all evening I think perhaps I'm
going to try and just run through this
twice more and call it a
[Music]
day honestly I think that I'm at the
point now where I'm just like kind of f
fued in general I am actually going to
do going to try and conserve my energy
I'm going to head back
inside going to pack up my camera gear
so I'm ready to go in another 4 hours
here definitely look over the game tape
too cuz I think that'll be helpful as
well screw it let's do just one more
take and then call it a
day not bad DX not bad all right let's
take that
inside and uh see what notes I might
have so we are 40 minutes away from me
heading down and shooting video of
Performing G's performance and I am such
a bundle of nerves I have been
practicing his piece um and I've been
pleasantly surprised to find that more
or less where I'm supposed to be but I
think that I'm in a pretty good position
overall so everybody keep your fingers
crossed for me cuz uh I'm definitely
nervous 9 o' y'all it's game time what
friends I made it down to the dance
studio I have all of this amazing room
to work with here tonight uh I'll check
back in when I've got my Lights and
Camera set up all right well we are
successfully set up I have my lights I
have my camera going to do a quick
warmup and then get rolling
[Music]
here ah
ha it is 5: till 11: right now and I at
least have my first usable take of the
evening a take that is close enough that
I wouldn't be unhappy in sharing it but
I think I have a better take still in me
so I still want to do maybe a couple
more takes and then probably wrap it up
for the
night
[Music]
oh my
God you were so close J you were so
[Music]
close
it is nearly
11:45 and I just got a take that I think
I'm happy
with it's time to call it a
night well hello friends it is day eight
and um I have to admit that I am
absolutely exhausted I'm proud of myself
for doing that work and
uh I can't wait to share this with the
world so let me share it with you right
now this is uh me doing G's performance
from San Francisco decom in 2008 and
I'll include uh G's video up in the
corner so you can compare our
[Music]
movements
oh
[Music]
n
[Applause]
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
n
overall I think my reactions to it are
positive I really wish that I'd had
enough chance I had had enough time to
get comfortable enough with this
performance to really just like dance it
up I can see my exhaustion in the video
but I'm also trying to remind myself
that I gave myself only a week to do
this even just getting it this close
inside of a week is pretty impressive I
think also real quick I just want want
to give Lantern Smith another thanks
your poy made this project possible I
would never have gotten this far in the
choreography without being able to dial
in my poy to getting this set up as
close as possible to what G was using so
thank you Lantern Smith um if y'all
would like to get a set of these emojo
poy which I would highly recommend
because they are super useful you can do
so by using the promo code drexfactor
with a zero instead of an O over
checkout at lanterns smith.com not only
will that get you a discount on your
order but it also helps out the channel
so everybody wins seriously I think
these are the most advanced and amazing
contact po out there in the market I
don't understand why everybody doesn't
already have a set all right all told
how do you think I did please be kind uh
leave me a comment with your feedback
I'd love to hear it also please be sure
to like uh share and subscribe to help
other people find the video and of
course to help my channel
grow
[Music]
thank you so much for watching this
video it would not have been possible
without the awesome support of my
patreon supporters in particular I'd
love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now uh if you'd like to check out uh the
reacts video that I did of G's
performance where I talk about what I
think makes the performance so good I
will go ahead and leave a link to that
down in the description or up on screen
if you're watching on YouTube also if
you'd like to support the channel I will
leave a link to my patreon down in the
description so check that out please
thanks once again have yourself a good
one get outside and flow and I'll see
you with another video real soon take
care now peace